en este vídeo vamos a continuar nuestra
travesía por el conocimiento de las
variables binomial es esta vez
intentaremos saber cuánto vale la
varianza de la distribución de una
variable binomial al igual que en el
vídeo pasado tengo esta variable
binomial x que es vista de manera
general es el número de éxitos después
de en ejecución es donde la probabilidad
de éxito para cada ejecución
independiente es p
por lo tanto la probabilidad de éxito en
una ejecución no depende de la
probabilidad de éxito en las otras
ejecuciones también vimos en el vídeo
pasado que el valor esperado de esta
variable aleatoria es n por t déjame
recordarlo y ponerlo por aquí el valor
esperado de esta variable aleatoria x es
el número de ejecuciones por la
probabilidad texto de cada ejecución ok
y esta expresión lo obtuvimos
considerando esta variable binomial como
la suma de n veces una nueva variable
aleatoria llamada bien como puedes ver
es una variable de berlín para esta
variable james la probabilidad de que
jesse igual a 1 es de pep es decir de
obtener un éxito y la probabilidad de
fracaso es decir de que sea igual a 0
era de 1 - p
por lo tanto puedes ver que las salidas
de james son 0 o 1 y eso es lo mismo hay
que tener un éxito o un fracaso en cada
ejecución de x
y ahora si sumas n bs obtienes en jeff y
esto nos serviría para obtener el valor
esperado de x que fue lo que hicimos en
el vídeo pasado esto es un repaso el
valor esperado de x salen del valor
esperado de james que es muy fácil de
calcular déjame ponerlo acá arriba el
valor esperado de james es igual a bueno
como sólo tenemos dos posibles salidas
es simplemente la probabilidad de p de
obtener uno déjame ponerlo la
probabilidad de p
debe obtener 1 me lo voy a poner con
este color ok ya esto sumarle la
probabilidad de 1 - p déjame ponerlo
aquí la probabilidad de 1 - p ok de
obtener 0
por 0 y si ahora observas esto de aquí
es simplemente cero y me queda que el
valor esperado de este es simplemente p
por 1 lo cual es p ok y con esto
deseamos que por la propiedad de la suma
del valor esperado el valor esperado de
x es igual a la suma de todos estos
valores esperados es decir a la suma de
todos los valores esperados de cada
quien y por lo tanto decíamos que el
valor esperado de x
esto era igual a veces
a veces el valor esperado de que el
valor esperado de ser que como ya vimos
es pep y entonces concluyamos que esto
era igual a n por p que era justo a lo
que queríamos llegar y esta era la forma
de demostrar esta igualdad que tengo
aquí y ahora vamos a aplicar la misma
idea para obtener la varianza de x la
varianza de x va a ser igual a la suma
de las varianzas de éstas en ejes así
que de manera similar déjame escribirlo
aquí la varianza de x
va a ser igual a n veces la varianza de
que así que lo voy a poner así
nps es la varianza de g
y ahora nos tenemos que preguntar cuánto
vale la varianza de james bueno qué te
parece si la obtenemos de este lado la
varianza de g
va a ser igual a quien bueno va a ser el
valor esperado de los residuales al
cuadrado así que tengo la probabilidad
en déjame ponerla la probabilidad pm que
multiplica a un residual elevado al
cuadrado y la pregunta es cuál es este
residual bueno en el primer caso tenemos
a uno menos el valor esperado que como
ya vimos en este caso es vean es decir 1
- p esto elevado al cuadrado esto para
la primera salida posible el residual al
cuadrado por el peso de su probabilidad
ahora para la segunda entrada
posiblemente tengo una probabilidad
déjame ponerlo más una probabilidad de 1
- p está para mi segunda entrada que va
a multiplicar
a un residual al cuadrado y quien va a
ser este residual bueno va a ser el
valor que toman 0 ya esto le vamos a
quitar el valor esperado que es p y esto
lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado y ahora
podemos simplificar un poco todo esto si
lo simplificó me va a quedar que esto es
igual a ap que multiplica a 1 - p esto
elevado al cuadrado más y aquí tengo
cero menos pm elevado al cuadrado bueno
eso es p cuadrada que multiplica a 1 - p
y ahora de todo esto puedo factorizar
una p que multiplican a 1 - p ok y esto
a su vez está multiplicando a quien
vienen veamos aquí me quedan 1 p 1 - p y
acá me quedan más p de lujo y ahora
observa menos p más p estos dos se van
así que todo esto es simplemente 1 y ya
puedo decir que esto se simplifica
simplemente ap por 1 - p de lujo por
cierto esta es la varianza de una
variable binomial de hecho esto ya lo
probamos en otros vídeos no estaría mal
que los revisadas entonces ya lo tenemos
en lugar de la varianza de gem voy a
poner p que multiplican a 1 - p muy bien
y ahora es cuando debería de sonar un
redoble de tambor porque ya podemos
decir que la varianza de x va a ser
igual a
que multiplican ap por 1
p perfecto y ahora qué te parece si
regresamos al ejemplo concreto del vídeo
pasado donde n eran 10 tiros penales
eran 10 tiros penales es decir que cada
ejecución es un tiro penal
y además teníamos una probabilidad de
meter un gol de 0.3 es decir un 30% de
anotar un gol cada vez que tirábamos un
penal entonces en este caso puedo decir
que la varianza de x está va a ser igual
a él en que en este caso es 10 que va a
multiplicar a la probabilidad que en
este caso es de 0.3 ok que a su vez va a
multiplicar a 1 - p
por lo tanto 10.3 es 0.7 y entonces me
quedan 10
0.3 por 0.7 es 0.21 y bueno eso es 2.1
así que está de lujo esta es mi varianza
y si quisiera la desviación estándar
simplemente tendría que tomar la raíz
cuadrada de este valor o visto de una
manera general tendrás que tomar la raíz
cuadrada de esta expresión hasta la
próxima